The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to lecture
number two.
In this lecture, I would like to
discuss some basic concepts
of finite element analysis with
regard to the analysis of
continuous systems.
We discussed in the first
lecture already some basic
concepts of analysis of
discrete systems.
However, in actuality, in the
analysis of a complex system,
we are dealing with a continuous
system, and there
are some additional basic
concepts that are used in
analysis of continuous
systems, using
finite element methods.
And those additional concept
that are used, I want to
discuss in this lecture.
Well, when we talk about the
analysis of a continuous
system, we can analyze that
system via a differential
formulation or a variational
formulation.
If we use a differential
formulation or variational
formulation, of course we obtain
continuous variables,
and we have an infinite number
of state variables, or rather,
if we talk about displacements,
a U
displacement, for example, of a
rod, as I will be discussing
just now, we will have infinite
values of that
displacement along the rod.
In the differential formulation
or the variational
formulation, we would have to
solve for that continuous
variable along the rod.
Well, we will also notice that
in the analysis of a complex
system, we cannot solve the
differential equations that we
are arriving at directly,
and we have to resort
to numerical methods.
Now, some concepts that have
been used for a long time are
the weighted residual methods.
These have been used by
Galerkin least squares
approaches to solve the
differential equations that
govern the equilibrium motion
of the system approximately.
In the variational formulation,
the Ritz method
has been used for quite
a long time.
These are classical techniques,
therefore,
weighted residual method
and the Ritz method.
And what I want to show to you
in this lecture is how the
finite element method is really
an extension off these
methods, or how this method, the
finite element method, is
related to these classical
techniques.
Well, when we talk about the
differential formulation, we
are looking at the differential
equilibrium, or
the equilibrium of
a differential
element of the system.
Now, I want to show to you the
basic ideas of a differential
formulation by looking at,
or analyzing, this rod.
Here we have a rod that is fixed
at the left-hand side,
on rollers.
x is a variable along the rod.
u is the displacement of that
rod into this direction.
The rod is subjected, as shown
here, to a load , R0
at its right end.
Notice that in this analysis, we
assume that plane sections
remain plane.
In other words, a section that
was originally there at time t
greater than 0 has
moved to here.
And this movement here is
the u displacement.
But notice that the vertical
section here remains vertical
during the motion.
So at every section, we have
only 1 degree of freedom.
There's no rotation
of that section.
However, this one degree
of freedom, u, varies
continuously along the rod.
Therefore, the rod itself has
really an infinite number of
degrees of freedom.
For this very simple
system, we could
obtain an exact solution.
However, I want to show you how
we proceed in analyzing
this rod via differential
formulation, a variational
formulation, and so on,
simply as an example.
Therefore, the basic ideas,
really, that I will be putting
forth to you, that I will be
discussing with you, are
really the important things that
I want to expose to you.
It's not the analysis of this
very specific problem.
It's really the basic idea that
I want to clarify to you
by looking at this
one problem.
Well, for this problem here,
the governing differential
equation of motion
is shown here.
Notice u once again is the
displacement of a section.
That is, this displacement here
at that coordinate x.
c is given here as square root E
over rho, where E is Young's
modulus of the material,
rho is the mass
density of the material.
t, of course, is the
time variable.
Notice the cross-sectional
area a here, I have also
written down here.
This cross-sectional area
cancels out on both sides, as
you will see just now.
Now this question here is
obtained in the differential
formulation by looking at the
equilibrium of an element.
And we might consider this to be
the element that I will now
focus our attention on.
Here we have that element
drawn again.
This element here of length dx
is subjected at its left side,
because x comes from here as a
variable and brings us up to
this station.
At the left side here, the
element is subjected to sigma,
the stress sigma.
At the right side, we have
the stress sigma plus
partial d sigma dx.
This here really means nothing
else than a d sigma, an
increment in the sigma.
Well, the equilibrium
requirement for this element
here is now that the force on
this side here, that is, sigma
times a on this side, which is
actually this one here, I
should have pointed
to this one--
and this force here, which is
the force on the right side.
If we subtract these two forces,
that must be equal to
the force applied.
Or rather, the d'Alembert
force.
Notice that if we look at this
element, there's a force on
the right, there's a
force on the left.
And this being the force on the
right, let's call that,
say, R1, and let's
call that R2.
So I put here R1,
I put here R2.
And R1 minus R2 must be equal to
the d'Alembert force, which
is due to the inertia
of the material.
This is the basic Newton's
law applied to this
differential element.
Now, if we referred back to
how we proceeded in the
analysis of a discrete system,
we really proceeded in exactly
the same way.
But our element then was a
discrete element, a discrete
spring element.
We now use the same concept, but
apply those concepts to a
differential element.
So this is the equilibrium
equation of the element.
The constitutive relation
is given here--
that the stress is equal
to e, the Young's
Modulus, times the strain.
This is the strain.
And notice once again, since we
are considering sections to
be remaining plane, and simply
move horizontally, the only
strain that we're talking
about is this one.
If we combine these two
equations here, we directly
obtain that equation here.
Notice as I mentioned earlier,
a cancels out.
If a is constant, that's why
a does not enter into this
equation, and this substitution
for sigma into
here gives us the second
derivative here.
Of course, this part here
cancels out that part there,
and that second derivative
is this one here.
The E brought over to this
side gives us a 1 over c
squared, where c, once again,
is defined as shown here.
The important point, really, is
that we are looking here in
the differential formulation at
a differential element of
length dx at a particular
station x.
That we're looking at this
element and we establish the
equilibrium requirement
of that element.
R1 minus R2 shall be equal to
the mass of the element times
the acceleration.
We also introduced a
constitutive relation.
So far, clearly, we have used
two conditions for the
solution of the problem.
The first one is the equilibrium
condition.
The second is the constitutive
condition, or constitutive
requirement.
We have to ask ourselves,
where do we satisfy the
compatibility condition?
Because there are always these
three conditions that we have
to satisfy.
Well, the compatibility
condition is satisfied by
solving this differential
equation for this rod, and
obtaining a u that
is continuous.
In other words, a u that tells
that all the sections have
remained together.
We did not cut that bar apart.
In the discrete system analysis
of the spring system
of lecture 1, if you were to
think back to it, we had to
satisfy the compatibility
condition explicitly, in
establishing the equilibrium
equations, because we had to
make sure that all the springs
remain attached to the carts.
Here we satisfy the
compatibility condition by
solving this equation
for a continuous u.
Well, the boundary conditions,
of course,
also have to be stated.
And here we have a boundary
condition on the
left end of the rod.
Remember, please, that the rod
is fixed at its left end, so
we have this condition here,
and clearly u must be 0 for
all times t at x equals 0.
At the right end, we
apply a load R0.
And there we have, this being
here the area times the stress
at x equals L, E
times a du dx.
Notice that E du dx is, of
course, the stress, and so we
have here this total force
at the right end
being equal to R0.
We also have initial conditions
for the solution of
this equation that I showed to
you, this equation here.
We have to have two spatial
conditions, two boundary
conditions, one at the left
and one at the right end.
The ones that I just
showed to you.
We also have to have to have two
initial conditions, one on
the displacement and one
on the velocity.
Well, their initial conditions,
in this particular
example, might be
as shown here.
At time 0, all of the
displacement are 0.
And at time 0, all
the velocities
along the rod are 0.
So the basic differential
equation given here, once
again, plus these boundary
conditions, plus these initial
conditions, define the
complete problem.
I also like to point out here
that this boundary condition
here, which does not involve any
derivative, is called an
essential, or displacement
boundary condition.
An essential boundary condition
because it does not
involve any derivative when,
and this is important, the
highest derivative in this
differential equation is 2.
The right-hand side boundary
condition is called a natural
force boundary condition.
It's really involving forces.
And it involves, as a highest
derivative, a derivative of
order 1 when the differential
equation here involves as the
highest derivative a derivative
of order 2.
So in general--
and this is a very
important point--
we can say the following.
If the highest order of the
spatial derivative in the
problem governing differential
equation is 2m, in our case, m
is equal to 1 for our problem.
The highest order of the spacial
derivative in the
essential boundary condition
is m minus 1.
In other words, in this
case, of order 0.
The highest order the spatial
derivative in the natural
boundary conditions that I just
discussed is 2m minus 1,
which is 1 in our
particular case.
Then if we talk about this
problem, we talk about a C m
minus 1 variational problem.
It will become apparent
to you later on why we
call it this way.
C m minus 1 means continuity
of order m minus 1.
In fact, in the Ritz analysis
that we will be performing
later on, that I will discuss
with you later on, we find
that we need, in the solution of
that kind of problem, only
continuity in the Ritz functions
of order m minus 1.
Well, let us now look at the
variational formulation.
I mentioned earlier that we have
two different approaches.
The first approach is a
differential formulation, the
second approach is the
variational formulation.
The variational formulation
operates in much the same way
as I introduced it
to you for the
analysis of discrete systems.
We talk about pi a functional,
being equal to the strain
energy minus the potential
of the loads.
Now for the rod, the strain
energy is given here.
Notice this is 1/2 times the
stress times the strain, and
integrated over the total volume
of the element, or of
the rod, I should rather say.
The total potential of the
loads is given here.
I could have written it this
way, with a minus out there
and a plus in there--
same thing.
This, then, is really nothing
other than the loads
multiplied by the total
displacement.
And of course, there's an
integration involved here,
because the body forces, the
body loads that I introduced
here, fB, are varying along
the length of the rod.
I introduce these fB body forces
because I want to use,
later on, the d'Alembert
principle, put these, in other
words, equal to minus the
acceleration forces, and can
directly apply what I discussed
now, also to the
dynamic analysis of this rod,
which we considered in the
differential formulations.
Together with stating pi as
shown here, we also have to
state the left-hand boundary
condition, which is an
essential boundary condition.
We have to list all the
essential boundary conditions
here, or the displacement
boundary conditions.
Essential and displacement
mean the same
thing, in that sense.
Well, then we invoke the
stationality of pi.
We are saying that del pi shall
be equal to 0 for any
arbitrary variations of u that
satisfy, however, the
essential boundary conditions.
This boundary condition here.
So this has to hold, this
statement shall hold, for any
arbitrary variations in u.
However, del u 0 shall be 0,
that satisfy, in other words,
the essential boundary
condition.
Well, if we apply this variation
on pi, we obtain
directly this result here.
Notice that this part here is
obtained by applying the
variation on this part here.
The variation operator operates,
del operates, much
in the same way as a
differential operator.
So this tool cancels this at
1/2, and we are left with EA
del u del x times the variation
on del u del x.
And that is given right there.
The variation on this part here
gives us simply a del u
times fB, and a del uL times R.
Of course, uL is equal to
is the displacement at x equal
to L. And this is, therefore,
the final result.
Now if we look at this, we
recognize, really, that this
is the principle of virtual
displacement.
It's a principle of virtual
displacement
governing the problem.
In general, we can write this
principle as follows.
Notice that here, we have
variations in strains, which
is that part there.
The real stresses are given
there, which are those.
And here we have variations in
displacement, those operating
on the body forces.
There, there.
Notice, I sum here over all
body forces in general.
We have three components
in fB--
the x, y, and z component.
So I list these components in
a vector that I call fB.
Similarly, of course, we have
three displacement components
that appear here in this vector
U. Tau in general has 6
components.
Del epsilon also has
6 components.
Putting their transpose on the
del epsilon vector means that
we're summing the
product of the
strains times these stresses.
Similarly, we are summing
here the product of the
displacement components times
the force components.
We also have here
a contribution
due to surface forces.
fS are the surface forces.
3 components, again, these are
the variations in the surface
displacement.
So this part here, del uLR,
really corresponds to this
part here, involving
surface forces.
So the surface forces read
again, and the variations in
the surface displacements,
are those here.
Now notice that this principle
here, or this equation, I
should rather say, once again
has to be satisfied for any
arbitrary variations in
displacements that satisfy the
essential boundary conditions.
For the problem of the rod,
these del u's have to satisfy
the condition that the variation
at the left-hand
boundary on u is 0, because
that is the
essential boundary condition.
Also, of course, notice that
this variation in the u's
corresponds to these variations
in the strains.
In other words, these strains
here are obtained from the
variations in the
displacement.
That's important.
They are linked together.
So if we impose certain
variations in the
displacement, we have to impose
here the corresponding
variations in strains.
Of course, these variations in
the displacements give us also
variations in surface
displacement.
So these here are again
linked up with that.
Later on in our formulation of
the finite element method, we
will write the variations in
the strains here as virtual
strains, arbitrary
virtual strains.
And we are talking about the
strain vector with a
bar on top of it.
Similarly, a bar here, a
bar here, instead of
the variation sign.
However, the meaning is
quite identical--
what we are saying here, and
this is the principle of
virtual displacement that we
will be talking about later
on, when we formulate the finite
element equations, what
we are saying here really is
that this equation has to be
satisfied for any arbitrary
virtual displacements and
corresponding virtual strains.
However, the virtual
displacements have to satisfy
the displacement boundary
conditions, the essential
boundary conditions.
Well, from this, or rather that,
which of course these
equations are completely
equivalent, we
can go one step further.
And if we go one step further,
by applying integration by
parts and recognizing that this
part here is completely
equal to that, by that I mean
taking the variation on the
derivative of x is the same as
taking the sorry... by taking
variation on the derivative of
u with respect to x, that is
completely identical to first
taking the variation on u, and
then taking the differentiation
of that
variation on u with
respect to x.
Well, if we recognize that
these two things are
identical, then using
integration by parts on this
equation here, which means,
really, on that equation here,
for the special case of
the rod that we're now
considering, we directly obtain
this equation here.
The integration by parts is
performed by integrating this
relation here first, and notice
that if we do integrate
this, we want to lower the
differentiation of the virtual
part here and increase the order
of differentiation on
this part here.
And that then directly gives
us these two terms
and that term here.
If we then also list this part
here together with what we
obtain from that part, we
directly obtain this equation
here, and we proceed similarly
for the coefficients of del
uL, and we obtain
this part here.
So this equation here is
obtained by simply using
integration by parts on, I
repeat, this equation here.
We have not used
any assumption.
All we did is a mathematical
manipulation of this equation
in a different form.
And this is the new form
that we obtained.
Del u0, of course, is the
variation of u at x equals 0.
Now when we look at this
relation, we can extract now
the differential equation of
equilibrium and the natural or
force boundary conditions.
How do we extract them?
Well, the first point is that
I mentioned already earlier,
this part here is 0, because
del u0 is imposed to be 0.
So that part is 0.
We can strike it out directly.
Now when we look at this part
here and that part here and
recognize that del u is now
arbitrary, we can directly
extract the relation that this
must be 0 and that must be 0.
How this is done?
Well, first of all, we
recognize that this
integration here really goes
from 0 plus to L minus, if you
want to be really exact.
Because at the boundary, we have
the boundary conditions.
Of course, this 0 plus means it
is infinitesimally close to
0, and L minus, we are
integrating up to a distance
infinitesimally small to
actually L. So putting the 0
plus and L minus here is just
for conceptual understanding
really necessary.
Well, if we then impose the
following variations, say that
del uL is 0, is exactly 0,
then this part is out.
And then we only have to
look at this part.
Now we can apply any arbitrary
variation on u from 0 to L
minus, and this, then, this
total integration, must be
equal to 0.
It must satisfy the
0 condition.
And that can only be true when
this part here, what is in the
brackets, is 0.
Because if this is not 0, I can
always select a certain
delta u which, when multiplied
by that and integrated as
shown here--
remember, this part
is not there--
will not give us 0.
So therefore, this
part must be 0.
And that is our first condition,
which is the
equilibrium condition of
a differential element.
It's the equilibrium condition
of a differential element.
Now, if we say, let us look at
the right-hand side boundary,
and put del u0 everywhere along
the length of the rod,
except at x equals exactly L.
Then this part would be 0, and
this part here is non-zero,
provided--
or rather, this part
would be present.
And the only way that this part
can be 0, as it must be,
is that this part here, the
coefficient on del uL, is
actually 0.
So this way, we have extracted
two points, two conditions.
This part must be 0 and
that part must be 0.
We extract these conditions
by looking at specific
variations on u.
First we look at the variation
on u where del uL is 0, and
otherwise arbitrary from
x equals 0 to L minus.
And then we can directly
conclude this must be 0, and
second time around, we say,
let del u equal 0 from x
equals 0 to L minus, which makes
all of this integral 0,
and we can focus all our
attention on this part here,
and we directly can conclude
that this part now
must also be 0.
So this way, then, we extracted
the differential
equation of equilibrium and
the natural boundary
conditions.
Very important.
Differential equation of
equilibrium and the natural
boundary condition.
And now we really recognize.
of course, that if we put fB
equal to the d'Alembert force,
or minus the d'Alembert force,
equal to this right-hand side,
substitute from here back into
there, cancel out A, we
directly obtain this
differential equation.
Notice that c is E divided
by rho square root
E divided by rho.
Now, the important point really
is that by having
started off with this pi
functional and that condition,
this condition also, and that
the variations on u at x
equals 0 shall be identically
0, we directly can extract
from this pi functional the
differential equation of
equilibrium and the natural
boundary conditions.
The natural boundary conditions,
in fact, are
contained right in there.
That's where the natural
boundary conditions appear.
The essential boundary
conditions are there, and have
to be satisfied by
the variations.
So in general, then, we find
the following points.
The important points are that
by invoking del pi equals 0
and using the essential boundary
conditions only, we
generate the principle of
virtual displacement, an
extremely important fact.
And this will be the starting
equation that we will be using
to generate our finite element
equations later on.
We also can extract the
problem governing
differential equation.
Therefore, the problem governing
differential
equation is contained in the
principle of virtual
displacement, and this one is
contained in del pi equals 0,
in the del pi equals
0 condition.
Of course also satisfying the
essential boundary condition.
We also can extract the natural
boundary conditions.
So these are also contained,
in essence, in pi, and as I
showed to you, they're contained
really in w.
That's where they appear.
Now in the derivation of the
problem governing differential
equation, we used integration
by parts.
And the highest spatial
derivative in
pi is of order m.
We used integration by parts m
times, and what we're finding
is that the highest spatial
derivative in the problem
governing differential
equation is then 2m.
And this then puts together the
complete structure of the
equations that we're
talking about.
Here I have another view graph
that summarizes the
process once more.
We are starting with the total
potential pi of the system
being equal to the strain
energy minus the total
potential of the loads.
We're using this condition and
the essential boundary
condition--
very important--
to generate the principle
of virtual displacement.
At this stage, we can solve the
problem, and we will do so
by using finite element
methods.
We can, however, also go on from
the principle of virtual
displacement using integration
by parts, and then we would
derive the differential equation
of equilibrium and
the natural boundary
conditions.
We can solve the problem.
Well, we can solve the problem
at this level really only when
we can solve the differential
equation of equilibrium,
subject to the natural
boundary conditions.
And that we can really only do
for very simple systems.
Therefore, this process here,
from here onward, can really
be followed only for relatively
simple systems.
For complex systems, shell
structures, complicated shell
beam structures, plane stress
systems, real engineering
structural analysis systems,
this is not possible, and we
stop right there, and we solve
our problem this way, using
finite element methods.
Now, the one important point,
however, I want to make once
more clear--
when we proceed this way, we are
deriving the differential
equation of equilibrium for
each differential element.
And this means that when we go
this route for the simple
systems that we can go this
route, we satisfy the
equilibrium condition on each
differential element.
However, when we go this route,
we will find that we
only satisfy the equilibrium
conditions in a global sense,
in an integrated sense, using
finite element methods, and
that to actually satisfy the
equilibrium conditions in a
local sense, meaning for each
differential element, we have
to use many elements, and only
then, of course, our finite
element solution will converge
to the solution that we would
have obtained solving the
differential equation of
equilibrium.
Therefore, when we start from
the principle of virtual
displacement, if we, as I will
show you, use many elements,
we really obtain the same
solution as here.
However, if we do not use
many elements, if we
use a coarse mesh--
we will talk about a coarse
mesh later on--
then we will see that we only
satisfy the equilibrium
conditions in a global sense for
the complete structure, in
an integrated sense for the
complete structure.
For each finite element, we will
satisfy the equilibrium
conditions, but we will not
conditions accurately for each
differential element--
dx, dy, dz being arbitrarily
small--
in the continuous body.
That will become clearer, then,
when we actually go
through an example.
Now I mentioned earlier that
a whole class of classical
methods are the weighted
residual methods.
In the weighted residual
methods, we proceed in the
following way.
We consider the steady state
problem, which is given here,
with these boundary
conditions.
Now this operator L2m
phi equals R--
this L2m is the operator that
governs the problem.
Like in our particular rod
problem, L2m would be equal to
delta u delta x squared.
So the highest derivative in
this spacial operator being
2m, in this case, 2,
for our example.
The boundary conditions can
be written this way.
And the basic step, then, in the
weighted residual and the
Ritz analysis is to assume a
solution all of this form,
where phi bar gives us the
assumed solution ai are
parameters that are unknown,
and fi are bases functions.
These are functions that
have to be assumed.
Well, there is, of course,
considerable concern on what
kind of functions to choose.
In the weighted residual method,
these functions here,
if you directly operate on this
equation here, should
satisfy all boundary
conditions.
Notice that in the weighted
residual method, here I'm
really talking about going on
this view graph through the
differential equations of
equilibrium and natural
boundary conditions, deriving
them, if you want, via this
route, and then trying to
solve the problem here
numerically.
We will actually, as I said
earlier, in the finite element
process, go this route, but we
can also go that route with
the weighted residual methods.
In fact, there is a close
relationship between using
weighted residual methods at
this level and the Ritz method
at that level, the way I will
be describing it later on.
But in the weighted residual
method, this is the
assumption.
And then if we look at this
equation here, we can
construct an error
R, substituting
from here into there.
And that capital R error is
given by this equation.
Notice that this is, of course,
our trial function
that we have.
And if the right-hand side is 0,
everywhere over the domain,
then of course our error would
be 0, and we would have solved
our equation that we're
looking at here.
That is the equation
we want to solve.
Since if all of these functions
fi satisfy all of
the boundary conditions, then
we are satisfying these
equations, and all we have to
worry about further is to
satisfy this equation.
If R is 0, we would also satisfy
the differential
equation of equilibrium,
and we would have,
in fact, the solution.
However, that, of course, would
be a very lucky choice
on the fi functions.
In general, R will not
be identically 0
all over the domain.
In fact, how much R, or how
close R will be to 0 will of
course depend on the ai.
And this is then basically
our objective, namely, to
calculate ai values that are
making this R, this left-hand
side capital R, as close
as possible to 0.
And that can be achieved
via the
Galerkin method, for example.
This is the basic process.
Here we're substituting the R.
These are the trial functions,
and we're integrating the
product of these over the
total domain.
The domain here, in the case
of our rod, would simply be
the volume of the rod.
This is the mechanism that
generates to us n equations in
the trial parameters ai.
In another approach, the least
squares method, we would
operate on the square of the
error, and minimize the square
of the error when integrated
over the total domain with
respect to the trial
parameters ai.
That again gives us n equations,
and we set up these
n equations just as we're
doing here, to
solve for the ai.
Knowing, then, the ai, we can
back substitute into this
assumption here, and now
we have our approximate
solution, phi bar.
If the trial functions have been
selected to satisfy the
boundary conditions, then of
course phi bar will satisfy
the boundary conditions.
However, what phi bar will not
satisfy exactly is this
equation here.
However, we have minimized the
error in the satisfaction of
this equation in some sense
using the Galerkin method or
the least squares method.
These methods can also be
extended when the fi trial
functions do not satisfy all
of the boundary conditions,
namely, not the natural
boundary conditions.
They can be extended to their
places, but classically, they
have been used with trial
functions that satisfy all
boundary conditions.
When we were to extend the
Galerkin method for the case
where the trial functions do
not satisfy the natural
boundary conditions, then we
really talk basically about
already a Ritz analysis, and
that is the next procedure
that I want to introduce
to you.
Now of course, if we wanted to
really start deriving the Ritz
method from the Galerkin
approach--
in other words, if we wanted to
derive this Ritz analysis
method from the Galerkin
approach, we would have to
extend, first of all, this
Galerkin approach to include
the natural boundary conditions,
and then we would
have to perform integrations on
this equation, and we would
obtain the Ritz analysis
method.
The actual way of starting, of
introducing the Ritz analysis
method, is to introduce
it as a separate tool.
And it is introduced in
the following way.
Let pi be the functional of the
C m minus 1 variational
problem that is equivalent to
the differential formulation
that we talked about earlier.
Now, the differential
formulation that I talked
about here is this one.
That's a differential
formulation.
And as an example once again,
the operator L2m is del 2 u
del x squared.
There's a constant here.
We could also put an EA
in front here, but
that only is a constant.
It doesn't change the character
of the operator.
But this is basically the
operator for the problem that
we considered, and of course,
our boundary conditions are
also there.
So if we have a pi functional
that is equivalent to the
differential formulation given
in those two equations that I
just pointed out to you again,
then in the Ritz method, we
substitute the trial functions,
phi bar--
let us look at them again,
these are the trial
functions--
into pi, and we generate n
simultaneous equations for the
parameters that appear in this
assumption here by invoking
the stationality of pi.
Notice that by invoking that
del pi is 0, we really say
that del pi ai is 0 for all i.
And that gives us the condition
which we used to set
up the individual equations
that we need to set up to
solve for the trial
parameters ai.
Well, let us look at some
of the properties.
The trial functions used in the
Ritz analysis need only
satisfy the essential boundary
conditions, an extremely
important fact.
In the classical weighted
residual method, as I pointed
out, the trial function should
satisfy all boundary
conditions.
Therefore, they can be very
difficult to choose.
In the Ritz analysis method,
we only need to satisfy the
essential boundary conditions.
The application of del pi
equals 0 generates the
principle of virtual
displacement.
I mentioned that to you
earlier already.
And therefore, in effect, we use
in the Ritz analysis this
principle of virtual
displacement.
By invoking del pi equals 0,
we minimize basically the
violation of the internal
equilibrium requirements and
the violation of the natural
boundary conditions.
Well, remember that invoking
del pi equal to 0 and then
using integration by parts, we
actually generate, we could
generate the differential
equations of equilibrium and
the natural boundary conditions
the way I've shown
it to you, for the simple
bar structure.
Now, what I'm saying here is
that we do not want to
generate these differential
equations of equilibrium and
natural boundary conditions.
However, please recognize that
they are contained in the
equation del pi equals 0.
Therefore, by substituting our
trial functions, we violate
the internal equilibrium
requirements and the natural
boundary conditions, but
we will see that we are
minimizing that violation in
these conditions here.
Also, we will see that we
generate a symmetric
coefficient matrix, and K and
the governing equations then,
our KU equals R, that
we want to solve.
And that is really the basis of
the finite element method
for the analysis of continuous
systems.
Let me now go in detail
through an example.
Here we have is simple bar
structure which has an area 1
square centimeter from A to B,
and from B to C, B being this
point here where the
area changes and C
being that point there.
From B to C, we have
a varying area.
This variation in the
area is shown here.
It's 1 plus y/40 squared is the
area at any station y, y
being measured from point
B, as you can see here.
The length here is
100 centimeters.
This length is 80 centimeters.
The structure is subjected to
a load of 100 newtons here.
Notice that this arrow really
lies on top of that dashed
line we just separated out for
you to understand that there
is this arrow.
So this is the load
applied at the
mid-line of this structure.
We assume once again for the
structure also that there is
only the following displacement
mechanism.
If a section was originally
there, and it is a vertical
section to the midline, then
it has moved over, and I
grossly exaggerate now, to this
position, where this is
the displacement that we're
talking about u.
Grossly exaggerated,
of course.
So we're having a bar structure
subjected to a
concentrated load fixed
at the left end.
And our objective now is to
solve this structure, to solve
for the unknown displacement u,
being 0 here, of course as
a function of x, when
this structure is
subjected to that load.
Well, in the calculation of
this example, I want to
display to you as many
of the concepts
that we just discussed.
Here we have pi being equal
to this value here.
The strain energy
is given here.
Notice this is 1/2 times the
stress times the strain
integrated over the volume
of the structure.
The integration goes from 0 to
180, because that is the
length of that structure.
The total potential of the
external load is 100, which is
the intensity of the load times
the displacement at x
equal to 180... at
x equal to 180.
Well, the essential boundary
condition is that u is
0 at x equals 0.
I'd like to now consider
two different cases
for the Ritz analysis.
In the case one I want to use a
function that spans u, which
spans continuously--
and let me draw it out here--
from u, from x equals
0, to x equals 180.
That is the endpoint.
So here we have this function,
this part here and that part
there, these are the two trial
parameters that we
want to solve for.
And we will select them, we will
calculate them, rather,
using the Ritz analysis.
Case two, I also use trial
functions, but notice now that
I'm performing the following.
We have a domain AB--
let me go back once more--
a domain AB, and a domain BC.
And I want to now use one
function for AB and one
function for BC.
The AB function is simply this
one here, a linear variation
up to this point.
Now notice that UB is our
trial parameter--
that's the one we don't know,
our trial function parameter.
x/100 is simply is the function
that I'm talking about.
And notice that this function
only is applicable for this
domain where, let me put down
here the length that is x
equal to 100, and this is
here x equal to 180.
Now for this part here, I
use this function here.
Now notice what this
function does.
Well, if we look at this part
here in front, it involves uB,
which is also there,
and it involves uC.
uB, by the way, is the physical
displacement right
here into this direction.
Of course, I'm plotting u
upwards here to be able to
show it to you.
But the displacement, uB, is the
displacement of this point
B to the right.
uC is the displacement of this
point C to the right.
Then we recognize that this part
here corresponds really
to a variation such as that.
Notice when x is equal to 100,
which is that point, this
function here is 1.
When x is equal to 180, which is
that point there, this part
is equal to 0, because 180 minus
100 is 80, divided by 80
is 1, and 1 minus 1 is 0.
So this dashed line
corresponds to
this function here.
Let me put a dashed line
underneath there.
Well, if we now look at this
part here, we notice that this
part is 0, or this trial
function here is 0 at this
point B. And it varies linearly
like that across,
where this part here, of
course, denotes uC.
That is this one here, solid
black line, and here also,
solid black line.
Now the superposition of both
these functions, the dashed
blue and the solid black line,
give us this function here.
So the actual function that I'm
talking about is a linear
variation along here, and a
linear variation along here,
where I plot it vertically
up here--
uB and uC here.
Now, this is a specific case
that I want to draw your
attention on, because this
really corresponds, as we
shall see, to a true finite
element analysis.
And the reason for it is that
we're talking about one domain
here and another domain there.
And both of these domains are
identified as finite elements.
Well, the first step now is
to use pi, invoke the
stationality condition as we did
earlier, and this gives us
the principle of virtual
displacement.
I mentioned it earlier
already.
Our virtual strains are here.
The stresses are here.
The virtual work is
on this side.
I discussed it earlier
already.
We do not want to go
now via this route.
We first of all want to now
obtain the exact solution.
The exact solution is obtained
by using integration by parts
on delta pi, being, of course,
equal to 0, and extracting the
differential equation of
equilibrium for each
differential element
in this structure.
This means that if we are
talking here about the
differential element
equilibrium of each
differential element dx long
anywhere along the structure,
in other words, the equilibrium
of typically an
element like that.
That is a differential equation
of equilibrium.
And we also, of course, have
the natural boundary
conditions.
We can also derive the natural
boundary conditions.
The solution to this is obtained
by integration, and
this is the solution given.
Well, the stresses, then, of
course are obtained by
differentiation of the u's to
get strains, and multiplying
those by E, and these are
the stresses in the bar.
These are the exact stresses
in the bar that satisfy the
differential equations of
equilibrium and the natural
boundary conditions.
This is the exact solution of
this bar problem, the way I
have formulated it.
Now will perform our
Ritz analysis.
In case one, we use
pi equal to this.
Notice that I have substituted
now our trial functions
corresponding to case one
into the functional pi.
That gives us this term, that
term here, and that term here.
Notice that I have broken up the
integration from 0 to 100,
and 100 to 180, because the area
changes from over this
length here, and only for that
reason, really, I have broken
up the integrations.
Now this is pi.
And if we now invoke, we can
integrate this out, and then
invoke that del pi
shall be 0, we
obtain this set of equations.
We solve for a1 and a2,
substitute back into our
assumption that we had earlier,
and we got this u.
Notice that of course this u
displacement does satisfy the
essential boundary conditions.
It does satisfy the
essential boundary
conditions at x equals 0.
You can just substitute x equals
0, and you would see
that u is 0.
It does not satisfy, however,
the natural boundary condition
at x equal to 180.
Sigma is given here, obtained
by calculating the strains
from here and multiplying
by E--
this is our approximate solution
to the problem.
We are satisfying the
compatibility conditions,
because the bar has
remained together.
No material has been
cut away from it.
Also, we are satisfying the
constitutive relations, but we
do not satisfy the internal
equilibrium on a differential
local elements sense.
We do not satisfy the
differential equilibrium, and
we do not satisfy the natural
boundary conditions.
But we satisfy them in
an approximate sense.
Case two.
Here now we're talking about
our two linear functions.
And here we naturally integrate
from 0 to 100 for
the first linear function, and
from 100 to 180 for the second
linear function.
Notice this is, again, the area,
and notice that this is
here the strain squared.
It's strain squared here because
our E is out there,
which would give
us the stress.
And the area here, of course,
is equal to 1, which we did
not write down.
The important point is that this
is now our pi for these
two functions.
We again invoke del
pi equal to 0.
We obtain now this
set of equations.
We are solving from this
set of equations uB
and uC, given here.
Having got uB and uC, of
course we now have the
complete displacements along the
bar, because we only need
to substitute back into our
original approximations that
we looked at earlier.
Let me just get them
once more here.
We had them here.
If we now substitute from
uB and uC into these two
equations, we have the complete
displacement solution.
Of course, this is
an approximate
displacement solution.
And similarly, our stresses
are approximate.
Now on these last few graphs,
I have plotted the solution.
And notice that this is
here the direction x.
Here we have the point B, here
we have the point C, here we
have the point A. Our exact
solution, which satisfies the
constitutive relations,
compatibility relations, and
the differential equations of
equilibrium, and all bounded
conditions, is the
solid line here.
Our solution one, case one, Ritz
analysis, is the dashed
line here, and the solution
two is this dashed dotted
line, down there.
Notice that we are quite close
in our Ritz analysis to the
exact solution in the
displacement.
However, the strains and
stresses are obtained by the
differentiation of these
displacement solutions, and
here I show to you the
calculated stresses.
Again, point A here, point
B here, point C there.
The important point
is the following.
In the exact solution, we have
the stress of 100 in domain
AB, and then we have
this curve here, a
very high slope there.
And in our solution one, we had
this variation in stress.
Notice that it goes continuously
over the complete
domain, because our assumed
displacement function was
continuous also over this
domain, and its first
derivative was continuous over
this complete domain.
So that's why our solution one
is continuous there, and in
fact, we're seeing just the
straight line there, because
our displacement approximation
was parabolic.
Our solution two is exact
here, 100, and very
approximate here for
the displacement.
But notice that at the midpoint
between B and C, we
get very good results.
Now the important point really
is shown here on
the last view graph.
We note that in this last
analysis, we use trial
functions that do not satisfy
the natural boundary
condition, and I'm talking now
about the piecewise linear
functions, in other words, from
A to B and B to C each,
just a straight line.
We use trial functions that
do not satisfy the natural
boundary conditions.
The trial functions themselves
are continuous, but the
derivatives are discontinuous
at point B. Notice our
stresses here are discontinuous
at point B.
For a cm minus 1 variational
problem, the way I've defined
it, we only need continuity in
the m minus first derivatives
of the functions.
In this problem, m is 1, and
therefore we only need
continuity in the functions
themselves, and not in any
derivatives, because we only
need continuity in the m minus
first derivative.
The domains A and B and B and C
are finite elements, and in
actuality, we've performed a
finite element analysis.
This is all I wanted to
say in this lecture.
Thank you for your attention.